a lot of action over super bowl weekend
on my Instagram account i'm on instagram
at david pakman i put up a picture of a
sign from right outside our studio here
which says please stop stealing food /
drinks and this has been i want to be
super clear because i think people may
have misunderstood we have a shared
kitchen and fridge on our entire floor
we're in an office building and there
have been emails that have gone out and
more recently signs that have popped up
on the fridge and on the bulletin board
which say please stop stealing food /
drinks we're not stealing each other's
food I want to be super clear about
that's not what this is in reference to
but there clearly is some kind of an
issue and I spoke to a few friends about
this over the weekend and they said same
thing happens at my work I bring in food
and sometimes someone takes it and
there's really a short list of suspects
because there's maybe a dozen people
that work on this floor at the most it's
kind of like one of those murder
mysteries where the person who actually
did it is in the play you just don't
know who it is I think there's more than
12 people here is more like 22 or 24
something like that but yet it's not a
crazy number that are here regularly
during lunch for sure I mean I think in
terms of the likely suspect it's
probably 12 people or so I mean it's
sort of funny and also frustrating but
also it's kind of sad too because it
must mean that someone is hungry here
and doesn't have food with them yeah
that's pretty sad I mean I guess it's
good that so many people are going to
learn about this now yeah it'll really
help his cause I think you think that
idiot us airing this grievance on the
air may actually help the food's f.2d to
stop I don't see how it could hurt yeah
also I was at a super bowl party at a
friend's house over the weekend and I
posted this picture of a hole in the
ceiling and at a certain point I believe
it was right after the Patriots got to
within two points right so between that
last regulation touchdown and the second
of two extra points a friend of mine got
up and cheered and said yeah and then
just punched a hole right through the
ceiling in his excitement and it was a
stunning display of strength and and
patriot New England Patriots fandom but
he rents and
may cause a problem at some point in
terms of the landlord tenant
relationship if you know what I mean
yeah I mean that's that's pretty bad
usually when you're punching a hole
through the wall it's out of anger not
out of joy no this is pure joy yeah I
mean I guess that's a good thing and all
I mean the Patriots London let's put the
picture back up a friend of mine after
seeing this said you know I don't know
that I would even patch it I would just
stick a smoke detector in there don't
even connect it to anything just stick
it in there and the landlord maybe would
never notice because it's about that
size I like that idea yeah I mean it's
on the ceiling so you can book pretty
much anything there that will cover it
they won't have I'm on Instagram at
david pakman please follow me lots of
funny stuff including pictures of me
with babies and dogs which as we've
clicked quickly determined do really
well on Instagram go figure that's
what's going on there instagram.com
slash david pakman